six o'clock it's a monday morning it's  labor day we thank you for joining us on  good day and we have someone new joining  us here this morning it is heather mills  heather good morning to you good morning  good morning everybody out there thank  you for tuning in this morning i know a  lot of you are off work so we appreciate  that and i am excited to be sitting in  this chair yes and you will see a lot  more of me see it's a familiar face here  in las vegas you had to go a couple  miles south indeed i did yes i've been  here in the valley five years  i've acclimated and and uh you know i  love it a few miles south nate and just  a few numbers  heather knows this town this town knows  heather and  it seems like we've been together for a  while already so heather it's great to  have you thank you isn't that nice that  we make heather labor on labor day  straight into the feet to the fire yeah  straight into the fire